véronique laflamme porte parole du front
d'action populaire en réaménagement
urbain le frapru et hans brouillette
directeur des affaires publiques
corporation des propriétaires
immobiliers du québec la corpiq bonsoir
à tous les deux bonsoir
bonjour alors une des grandes questions
cette semaine on va essayer de régler ça
est ce qu'il y a ou non une crise du
logement elle monsieur brouillette nom
n'est pas de crise du logement aurait
déjà eu lieu au début des années 2000
mais là bon riad si on regarde montréal
à près de 5 % des logements qui sont
vacants et 10 % et total sont
disponibles même section occupé mais
dans le bail a pointé renouveler on
n'est pas dans une crise or devons rien
si différent avec des taux d'occupation
moins de 1 pour de -2 1%
j'avoue c'est pas facile pour les
locataires
bon alors là vous prenez la mesure du
taux d'inoccupation des logements madame
la flamme est ce que c'est une mesure
qui est la bonne ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le fait qu'il ya pas de
crise du logement
c'est une des mesures le taux
d'inoccupation est cette mesure là elle
nous inquiète parce que le taux
d'inoccupation est bas dans la très
grande majorité majorité des
municipalités du québec dans près de 60%
des agglomérations de recensement et des
régions métropolitaines qui sont
compilées par la société canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement à l'auto
d'inoccupation et de mortiers - du seuil
d'équilibré du marché des 2 3%
mais ce n'est pas que ça la crise oui il
ya une crise du logement vécue par les
sens les dizaines de milliers de ménages
locataires qui actuellement ont des
besoins urgents de logements donc cette
crise ce n'est pas seulement la pénurie
mais c'est également un problème
d'abordabilité donc un très grand nombre
de ménages locataires qui ne réussissent
pas à se loger décemment à un prix
qu'ils respectent leurs capacités de
paiement et sas ccc l'homme ça c'est une
autre mesure de la crise et elle touche
là beaucoup trop de gens on parle de 240
4000 ménages locataires
québec l'homme qui ont des besoins
impérieux bon vous la corpiq monsieur
brouillette vous avez pas tout à fait la
même vision des choses avait même laissé
entendre que c'était un peu une crise
inventé par des élus qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire par là bas est petit on
parle de la disponibilité des logements
il y en a et on a vu où cisco fait
création de valerie plame céda nom sur
le cadavre de demander aux locataires de
nos ports et forme une propriétaire
qu'ils allaient quitter leur logement
afin d'en trouver un autre donc
l'injustice musicale et déménagement si
on cherche un logement on libère un
autre sacré tout un tout un problème on
est en campagne électorale on comprend
que ce sont des choses peuvent arriver
eu un point important que soulever
madame la femme l'abordabilité moi
j'aimerais s'il vous plaît le projet
australien sens pour expliquer une chose
on a un problème d'abord comment on
définit l'abordabilité je vous donne un
exemple prenez un couple qui arrive très
bien à payer son loyer mais le couple se
sépare du jour ou lendemain le logement
devient inabordable de loyer devient
inabordable parce qu'au lieu d'avoir du
revenu dont un seul est ce que le
logement est véritablement moins
abordables bien sûr que non ce qui était
important de regarder et d'essai seul
problème c'est de l'abordabilité devrait
être observé à partir du coup
d'habitation et leur colle pas du loyer
je parle du coût de production des
logements de gestion les travaux les
taxes les assurances
une fois qu'on établisse à on comprend
qu'une partie de la population une
minorité mais qui n'est pas capable de
se payer des logements adéquats
compte tenu de leurs revenus et là il
faut intervenir il faut intervenir
rapidement
madame la flandre votre vision là dessus
deux choses ans au niveau de
l'abordabilité c'est effectivement un
problème urgent ceci dit on est en train
d'assister à un effritement du parc de
logements locatifs encore abordables
parce que les loyers monte en flèche
beaucoup plus vite que l'indicé des prix
à la consommation on parle de près de 6%
de hausse du loyer moyen savoie 6% de
hausse de tous les loyers mais quand
même alors que l'ipc était de -2 1%
cette année
alors ça cette explosion du coût des
loyers en train est finalement un
effritement du parc de logements
locatifs encore abordables les
stratagèmes se multiplient notamment
avec la spéculation immobilière pour se
débarrasser des locataires qui était ou
un payeur dont toutes les éditions pour
le profit dont on entend parler et il ya
aussi des hausses importantes de loyer
au changement de locataires dont tout
cela participe de cette crise j'aimerais
qu'on parle des effets de la fin des
mises sur le marché des logements
locatifs
monsieur brouillette vous vous vous
voulait me faire comprendre qu'on ne
saisit pas tous les enjeux pour les
propriétaires marc compétition la pire
chose qui peut arriver aux locataires
c'est d'avoir des propriétaires qui ne
sont plus intéressées à louer des
logements il tant qu'il y aura de la
construction de logements donc un
déplacement de l'offre tant qu'il y aura
des propriétaires intéressés à garder
des logements en mode locatif parce
qu'on aussi les reprendre vos familles
les revendre en condos ou même à
l'époque de louer à des touristes
il faut maintenir l'intérêt d'investir
donc si on ne maintient pas cet intérêt
da on a un effritement du parc
immobilier et oui ça kion rareté et les
brimades et on assiste un peu à ça le 4
on voit des évictions pour
agrandissement subdivision carrément d
éviction pour des rénovations qui se
font même pas c'est une conséquence de
politiques gouvernementales qui ont
perduré depuis des années où on ne
rémunère pas le propriétaire pour les
travaux majeurs qu'il fait on parle de
deux dollars d'augmentation de loyer
pour mes dollars de travaux
ça prend 1,43 pour amortir les travaux
donc il ya cette perte de logement perte
d'intérêt des propriétaires et qui est
prêt à acheter les humains sont des
investisseurs des compagnies de
construction qui vont où il est
rentabilisé mais on perd on perd une
offre qui est importante parce que des
locataires vont subir des élections ou
d'augmentation de loyer majeur c'est
selon le l'on comprend qu'il ya un
problème que ce soit du côté des
propriétaires ou des locataires c'est
pas rose en ce moment alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait madame la fia mais d'abord
monsieur brouillette parler d'eux des
crimes une ére on pense qu'elles
immobiliers très payant ce moment et qui
a de l'argent or le logement ce n'est
pas qu'un investissement c'est d'abord
et avant tout un droit un droit que nos
gouvernements se sont engagés à
respecter or il ya 90 % du parc de
logements locatifs qui est du logement
privé et il ya très peu d'alternatives
pour les ménages locataires qui n'arrive
pas et qui n'arrivent plus à se payer
ces logements hors de prix donc pour
leur famille ou pour pour eux mêmes et
française
mention madame la flamme françois
legault disait cette semaine on va en
faire plus on va voir investir davantage
et parlait des quinze mille logements en
construction se passer en fait c'est 15
mai logements là ça fait des années
qu'ils ont été budgétés et qui ont été
sont attendus il ya des projets qui est
actuellement finir par le bétail qui ont
été promises sept ans alors les quinze
mille logements sont insuffisants pour
répondre à tous ces besoins dont on
vient de parler pour vous donner une
idée il ya quarante mille ménages en
attente seulement comme une habitation à
loyer modique sans parler de tous ceux
et celles avec des revenus modestes qui
n'y ont pas accès et qui aurait besoin
par exemple d'une coopérative ou d'un
organisme sans but lucratif d'habitation
et malheureusement monsieur lebon a dit
s'il faut en faire plus on va en faire
plus mais il n'y a toujours rien sur la
table
outre ces fameuses unités attendu depuis
des années et ça empêche paris ment des
villes comme montréal et québec qui se
sont dotées de politique avec des
objectifs d'atteindre leurs objectifs
qui sont déjà insuffisants là pour
répondre aux besoins alors l'heure est
grave et il n'y aurait rien de concret
pour répondre à ses yeux ça et ça c'est
peut-être à plus long terme donc à très
court terme ce qui a été évoqué c'est
gel des loyers moratoire sur les
expulsions au monsieur brouille est sûre
c'est l'effet inverse c'est à dire que
plus d'un le marché ne s'est pas propre
au logement l'eau dans tous les marchés
quand on impose plus de restrictions
l'offre est moins intéressé les
investissements voyage va en faire moins
moi je suis d'accord avec madame la
flamme des jeunes dans la population qui
ne peuvent poursuivre le coup le coût de
production et de métier en bon état des
logements leurs revenus ne leur permet
pas de suivre l'inflation qui est plus
forte que l'inflation globale parce que
les taxes augmentent plus vite les
assurances aussi plus vite les coûts de
matériaux med avait été non disponibles
donc ce qu'il faut faire parce que vous
parlez de solutions madame s'étendent
aux astuces bien content qu'on y arrive
il faut que cette partie de la
population qui ne peut pas suivre les
coûts reçoivent une aide financière
directe et rapidement pour leur
permettre de se maintenir dans des
logements adéquats ou maintenant trouver
un meilleur mais si on on espère des
constructions dans 10 ou 15 ans ça
arrivera jamais on prend pas les bonnes
années devant moi que là pour le moment
la construction bat son plein il va y
avoir un rééquilibrage du marché très
bientôt
bah on l'espère très certainement pour
bien des gens qui se cherchent un
logement abordable il y en a pas
beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir été là ça fait plaisir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit